American cycles like the gayest book
ever written and I said yeah that's
pretty gay because of powdered bateman
so [ __ ] gay in the 1980s and 90s
novelist Bret Easton Ellis captured more
fully than anyone the excitement and
ennui of a wealthy and smug America that
was stumbling without knowing it into a
new century filled with terror
disruption and generalized hostility in
the book and movie versions of less than
zero the rules of attraction and
American Psycho
Ellis dissected what happens to a
society in which depth of feeling
becomes synonymous with failure to
thrive in this century Ellis is back in
his hometown of Los Angeles writing and
producing movies with the likes of
Lindsay Lohan and porn star James Dean
whose shambled personal lives might as
well have been scripted by Ellis in one
of his most darkly comic moments he's
also putting out one of the most
engaging and insightful podcasts
available on patreon talking with
everyone from Kanye West to Rose McGowan
to veteran writer director Walter Hill
about the ways in which the
entertainment industry is built upon an
unstable foundation of economic sexual
and political hypocrisy corporate
culture is the reason why James hadn't
got fired unlike Serna [ __ ] and not
like no it is corporate culture reason
talked with Ellis in his la condo about
the ways in which Hollywood is failing
to come to terms with ever-changing
methods of production and distribution
what he sees as the excesses of the me2
movement and our rapidly changing online
public discourse I think the market
class apology is one of those depressing
things that happen this year how can
someone who you really like and he had a
good time with and he's one of the good
ones over there whatever Mark Duplass
said 48 hours later be a racist
homophobic piece of [ __ ] jerk we'll also
get to the undeniable appeal of Donald
Trump not just a small-town America but
two denizens of Beverly Hills and we'll
talk about the aesthetic and political
implications of a world in which
American movies are increasingly made
with an eye towards pleasing audiences
and governments in foreign countries
you've been podcasting since about 2013
or so your most recent podcast coming
coming back after a brief hiatus is on
patreon yes tell us tell me what is the
goal of the podcast and what are you
hoping to do with it well the goal is
first of all to have fun there's no
reason to do this without having fun and
being engaged by what I'm talking about
I would hate to have the podcast be like
a job that I have to do and so we were
away for about a year we were at podcast
one and there was a bit of a problem
with advertising podcast one really
demanded advertising because of course
that's how they make money and that's
how the podcast would make money I was
having a problem with advertisers a lot
of advertisers weren't happy about how I
was reading the ads for example and they
wondered why I wasn't more enthusiastic
and I could get very enthusiastic about
movies I've seen but I just relayed all
of the information they add in a very
kind of monitor so like dulcolax is not
your night Dollar Shave Club yeah you
know these are good promise oh yeah they
are good products and I thought I was
giving them a kind of a classy patina by
not like overdoing it like Adam Carolla
or wherever and I like Adam Carolla but
he knows how to sell because he is a pro
at that I was not a pro at it and I also
got a lot of flack in social media
libraries analysis reading something for
only nuts you know the new nut mix that
is and you know I felt podcast one had
been great to me in terms of just giving
me total freedom to do whatever I wanted
and I felt I owed them the ads the ads
were just weren't working they weren't
working for my producer they weren't
working for me we looked around for
about a year only landed on patreon and
we decided we'd do that subscribe and
see if we could also make some money off
the podcast I don't think there's
anything wrong at all with charging a
dollar fifty for 90 to 100 minutes worth
of content we have pushed back on that
definitely but I mean do have pushback
on oh yeah there's a lot of a lot of
complaints a lot of people don't like it
but at the same time I feel that there's
this rhythm we only do it every two
weeks but we do produce it you know it's
not just me
on the mic with some random person and
we're talking about what happened
yesterday or what was going on in the
news
it's a culturally minded podcast about a
wide array of subjects and not
particularly political at all it's
really mostly about culture a film
culture TV culture and where it's going
and so the notion of the podcast is to
be a reflection of whatever's on my mind
in those moments it could be a review of
a film it could be a very long review of
a film it could be talking about the
latest TV season and occasionally I'll
dip my toe into the hypocrisy of
Hollywood and I will dip my toe not into
politics no because I'm honestly not
that interested in politics but in terms
of the hypocrisy of the media the
hypocrisy of Hollywood and how that
bounces off against politics I will
occasionally do a show like that that is
often ridiculously controversial for
some reason among my audience but um the
podcast is it's you know I noticed when
I was writing long-form articles that
people weren't really reading the whole
article they were reading like the pull
quotes they were reading the first
paragraph maybe skimming it and that was
very new to me about 2013-2014 oh this
is really interesting people are not
reading the whole thing because they see
stuff on message boards about why
Danelle let's say that's why is he going
on and I and if you just went for
paragraph down whatever but I was
shocked to find out that people would
listen to an hour-long podcast or two
hour long part that's like you were
saying I mean the most recent ones I
mean it's almost it can be 15 or 20
minutes of you essentially reading an
essay or talking through or view of a
movie or things that is and we also edit
the podcast we produce it we had music
use my editor on it is terrific really
speeds it up gives it a pays there's no
lags there's no long pause or anything
like that so it is kind of a production
and you want to make it as listenable as
possible and we also want them to be
kind of a library of podcasts that you
can go back and listen to if it's about
a filmmaker you you want to have a deep
dive with it did a very long Walter Hill
that a lot of people referenced that
Alliance at Walter Hill owes Walter you
is don't know I do I was gonna say for
these damn Millennials who come up with
a for a fair amount of grief and you're
in your regular conversation they do but
I also live with one and I've been
living with one for eight years so I
feel that grief is earned and I feel
that I can with some degree and you are
what you're the last year of the baby
boom or the very start of Jana depending
on what chart you see I'm one of the
other but I've always identified with
Gen X and not the baby boomers but
Walter Hill was a kind of I would say
now though it didn't seem like it then a
kind of Vanguard
member of the new Hollywood not as
famous as Scorsese or Spielberg De Palma
are almond but he was a journey man a
studio film maker who made studio films
but in a very personal idiosyncrasies
studio movies that are undeniably
Walters the true occur and the original
idea of that theory that you're given
material but somehow you make it your
own under many construed that was the
seven yeah that was basically my
seventies and I always think of he's
he's kind of like the half-brother the
stepson of Don Siegel somebody like that
yes exactly but he never really made
giant personal movies like Close
Encounters of the Third Kind or The
Godfather or taxi driver one of the
great movies of the 70s were that really
were a distillation of that filmmakers
sensibility and was a continuum of
everything that they did
Walter Hill kind of jumped around in
John Rose and he made movies as as
distinct from each other as the driver
who never remembers a driver but I think
he really came into commercial success
with the Warriors that gaining picture
that came out in 1979 I didn't mean 48
hours and he made a movie called
Southern Comfort ooh made a very good
Western called the long riders well he's
in his 70s he had a movie out called the
assignment and he was in town he lives
in town but he was making the rounds of
all the podcasts and I realized I was
going to be the last one he was doing
and I was listening to some of the
podcasts that he was appearing on and I
just felt that they weren't doing a deep
enough dive I mean
Marc Maron would ask a question like oh
you're quite the stylist aren't you and
it was like where do you go with that
kind of question and again I mean I like
Marc Maron I've been on his show but he
basically has your Wikipedia page open
Lina's garage while he's you know
talking to you and he and you know I
don't blame him if you're doing two
major interviews a week how do you keep
up and he's also eat but he's also
generally a fan so you can't really slam
him for that in a way but it was
frustrating here so I was able to do
like a two-hour thing with Walter Hill
and you know that's kind of gratifying
my favorite interviews that I did were
really with old Hollywood directors
whether it's Peter Bogdanovich Paul
Schrader and you know laboratory
Schrader did collaborate was straight
again and you ever collaborate with him
again no I won't
I've dinner with them again but I don't
know if I'll collaborate with them and
he's picking up the check or it's split
down the middle
I don't think Schrader has ever picked
up they know what is it about these
older Hollywood directors that you find
so interesting well but but I also have
had young no no I know
Tarantino has been on Shaun Baker you
know a lot of a lot of other directors
young directors have been on but that
still to me is the most interesting
decade in American film I'm not saying
it's necessarily the best I mean I am
now on an old movie kick in terms of the
30s 40s 50s I really do think that maybe
that kind of old-school craftsmanship
might now be to me the true art of
making a film whether it's Lubitsch or
whoever compared to I mean because a lot
of crap was made in the 70s - let's not
let's not get our heads you know all you
know we like the night about this but
what's a crap movie from the 70s
um race with the devil you know what I
always I love that movie as a kid I saw
many times I'm always tempted to turn it
on when I come across it an Apple what
is a crap movie of the 70s I mean I
don't know
would you everyone would you consider it
maybe like jaws to be a crap movie
regardless of its cultural impact well
interestingly or Close Encounters is a
infantile movie but jaws and Close
Encounters are also intensely personal
new Hollywood movies and what made jaws
and then of course Star Wars have such
an impact was that they were essentially
b-movie pictures made on an a level with
money budget money and backing but also
a sensibility they took them very very
seriously I don't think there'd been a
movie like jaws that it taken itself so
seriously on such a grand scale which is
part of the excitement of that movie and
I have to say I think Close Encounters
one of the great achievements of 70s
filmmaking because it's such a personal
movie but it's also an epic UFO film is
also a conspiracy theory movie it's it's
about the 70s
it's about Watergate it's about boomer
discontent right it's about the me
generation you know embodied by Roy
Neary the character the Richard Dreyfuss
plays so on one level and it was
remarkable watching the movie in its
fortieth rerelease last fall how
beautiful it was how the studio lets
Spielberg do really pretty much whatever
he wanted and he has this amazing
looking movie that has a propulsion
that's kind of like very gripping sci-fi
plot going on and yet you can also just
see how much it tapped into the moment
and also really how kind of
uncompromising it was in some of its
family scenes which Spielberg had cut
out in 1981 really heralding fight
scenes between Teri Garr and Richard
Dreyfuss and he leaves the family I mean
he just leaves the family and goes up
into the spaceship and I really don't
know if you could do that now without
panic you notice your millennial
roommate does he look at Close
Encounters and he's like this is [ __ ]
worse than you know than a silent movie
look man I guess buried beneath that is
do you find the 70s you know that the
long seventies and
cinema that decade do you find it
endlessly fascinating because it also
just happens to correspond with your
childhood and adolescence of course it
does because I meet so many younger
filmmakers who rhapsodize about the 90s
the independent movie the movement of
the 90s which sure was quite exciting
it's it to a degree but it definitely
has everything to do with where when you
came of age but I also I still think
you're talking about grand movies made
in the 70s on a very lavish scale that
are very personal made by the studio's
the indie movement of the 90s was almost
a DIY affair it wasn't made on such a
grand scale it was independent cinema I
mean the 70s was Studio movie backing
and you can't imagine you know a studio
even in the 90s making a Clockwork
Orange or a taxi driver or whatever so
you know it's some he I actually showed
him a lot of movies when we first
started living together because he
really didn't have a framework for that
time and I have to say he was pretty
thrilled by what I was showing him
whether it was the last picture show or
Dog Day Afternoon or Carrie or a lot of
movies highlights from that era the
Godfather for example she never and so
he was um he was really thrilled and he
couldn't believe that movies had been
made like that back then but he also was
raised in a particular time where movies
were the weekend movies were what is the
number-one movie this weekend what are
we all going to see and that is kind of
how he experienced movies with that
moment when everything changed and
everyone became obsessed with box office
which had actually happened in the 80s
but um but so he was kind of amazed that
American film was kind of like an art
form in a very distinct way from how mu
and on a grand scale compared to how
movies are made out and now they're
watched
[Music]
you're from LA you move back to LA do
you feel like film is the is still the
paradigmatic American art form is it as
important as it was saying the 70s or
80s has it been supplanted by television
clearly novels which is you know writing
which is where you got your start that
seems to I mean it persists but it
doesn't seem to be as important as
movies or TV or music the novel as a way
of imparting information the novel in
terms of a novel comes out and you're
introduced to a world you've know
nothing about it's much talked about
it's like it's like almost like a news
bulletin from the front that kind of
novel doesn't really exist anymore
because you can find out whatever you
want whenever you want
via internet and a novel isn't the uses
of the novel are different than they
once were and I don't think people go to
novels that way I mean less than zero is
a classic example lesson zero was sort
of seen as this document about what kids
are up to today as much as it was a
novel and certainly there were novels
that would my mother who I've never as
far as I know never read a novel but she
read something about that book in 1985
or 86 shortly after came out and she was
like make don't go to any of those
parties where they show snuff movies
right and it was like okay bomb yeah
although I think if you show up and
they're showing one it's too late right
it's over you know it's completely over
but I do think that novels don't work
that way anymore films certainly their
place in the culture has diminished
greatly in terms of being at the center
of a conversation being the center of
the conversation for the kind of for the
cultural intelligencia you're saying
like rampage or you know the next Fast
and Furious movie isn't going to play
the same role in America as The
Godfather did or is I mean when you put
it that way it sounds rather naive I
mean but yes of course it but still
there are cinephiles
and still there are believers you can
find them everywhere from Quentin
Tarantino to Christopher Nolan to
Scorsese and there are more film
festivals than ever there are more
there's more film crew
than they've ever been there is more
attention placed on movies in a way that
we've never seen before it's just that
the movies aren't very good and they
just don't for the most part they're not
being made with the kind of care and
expense that many of the meat I see
movies all the time that I realized oh
they couldn't do that because they're
not the money for the party oh they
couldn't do that so they just have three
characters throughout the entire movie
oh they can't show the scene where they
go on to the beach or they walk to the
top of the skyscraper because they
didn't have the money and I think not
having the money is a huge limitation to
what you can do with film because there
is a ton of money for movies it's just
the movies that are gonna get that kind
of nearly unlimited budget are also ones
now that have to play for a global
audience which puts different
constraints on what type of movie are
gonna be made but that movie you just
talked about is only be made for the
global right hands and you see it like
all over the place I mean I saw the
Mamma Mia sequel here we go again and I
couldn't believe how much attention had
been paid to the global needs of the
box-office in terms of a kind of bland
inoffensive
cleanliness in terms and also a kind of
borderline dumbness of where anybody in
any language can understand exactly
what's going on in every scene because
of the you know facial expressions of
the characters and I'm sure I mean since
70% of the global audience is not going
to be seeing this movie in it's in their
language that's kind of what the demands
are and that's true for all the Marvel
movies as well and so what you've lost
is a kind of idiom and an idiosyncratic
American idiom as gone from from a
certain kind of lavishly made movie and
so you are stuck with either the 250
million dollar Marvel movies or you're
dealing with independent films that
they're lucky thing at 6 to 7 million
dollars for a high in indie so that's
just story enough people find ways to
make movies all the time more movies
than ever are being made it's just that
they're like they just don't what have
to be on the
you know and people could argue about
this I try I'm snobby I like certain
things but I want to be anti elitist in
this in this sense of saying yes certain
things are going to be dumbed down so
Mamma Mia instead of being you know you
know a Bergman desk film it's gonna be
reduced to there's a middle there's a
middle for sure but then there are there
are political and ideological
implications of that too so like when
Matt Damon is playing a Chinese warrior
on the Great Wall of China they're gonna
be changing all sorts of things I mean
for God's sake you know the the remake
of Red Dawn couldn't have what North
Koreans or Chinese as the villains this
time or something a character and Doctor
Strange had to be changed from an
ancient Tibetan wise man to tilda
swinton
yes just that kind of stuff trouble you
or is that just part of the you know
this is what happens well trouble I mean
look real-life troubles me much more
than the movies do but since I feel
invested in movies and I always have I
guess so that I mean changing certain
elements in material to please the
Chinese well morally how does one feel
about that how does one feel about the
fact that there is no longer gay
representation in studio movies because
they need to play globally they need to
play in Russia they need to play in
China and if you even have a hint of
gayness in a movie now like the very
innocuous gay aspect in Beauty and the
Beast the the live-action remake that
came out last year it's edited or is
rated R it's restricted in other
countries and this is a g-rated being a
PG rated movie that is kind of that is
kind of troubling but it also is
indicative of the hypocrisy of Hollywood
and it's very indicative of how
Hollywood thinks it's so progressive and
that they are so into inclusive
inclusive 'ti and diversity and all of
this stuff but really they're into money
and they want to make money and it's the
most nothing wrong with I mean you're
not you're not you're certainly not a
socially not at all no and I totally
believe in it but it is it doesn't want
to acknowledge that
is the most one of those capitalistic
businesses in the world you know it is I
mean it's just it's it's what it wants
to put out about itself and what it
really is that is the disconnect that is
bothersome to a lot of people that a lot
of people go and I think it's really
happened in the last two years where
Hollywood has shown itself to be well
transparent in terms of how people now
look at it it's not it's trying to do
all of these things to be progressive
but really it's just tripping up over
itself a time so and again Harvey I mean
to put a in horrible language of anti
because that's all I can do but it's
Harvey Weinstein would make sure that no
horses were hurt on the set of a Miramax
movie but he might be jerking off into
the face of an actress yeah is this is
this I tend to the meat too well the
meat movement of where you know
Hollywood has to come to terms with the
fact that it's a casting couch you know
that's a big casting couch and that
everyone knows the casting couch
I guess so to some degree I mean it was
very interesting there was this website
briefly that appeared that had all of
the women who had appeared in Miramax
movies throughout the 90s who never came
out and said a word and you know what do
infer from that and does it matter
I mean Harvey Weinstein gave an
interview I think to tacky that
Acropolis where he was talking about how
it was a casting couch doesn't everybody
realize in Hollywood there is a casting
couch there is to a degree there are you
know favours exchange no one talks about
its loosely I wrote a novel about it
Imperial bedrooms where it became very
apparent that the producer of a movie is
demanding that the young actress sleep
with him in order to get a part not
uncommon let's say it I'm not gonna say
it's common not uncommon
sexual favors are passed around a lot
but and not always unwelcome either no
no an understanding a quid pro quo it's
a quid pro quo and so it's and there's
an understanding to it now of course
that doesn't excuse rape doesn't excuse
sexual assault and it doesn't excuse
black
listing people Eva that's all bad news
very bad news but it does seem you know
the movement seems to have gotten
hysterical in a way that underlined kind
of like I don't know how to say this
kind of like messes up its initial
message and I think that that is kind of
a problem why so many people do not take
the me to movement seriously as they
once did and I talked about this on a
lot last podcast I talked to a lot of
women who find it embarrassing who don't
believe in it at all who really look it
as a Hollywood thing that is
particularly a Hollywood problem and
that many women I know do not see
themselves as victims of the patriarchy
many members females my family I have
female friends who just do not buy into
that you can buy into that package or
you don't have to buy into it and I
think when Terry Crews became the face
of me too a lot of people dropped out a
lot of people just said okay this is
absurd I mean if that person if Terry
Crews can go to Washington DC and start
talking about how he's a victim and he's
been an abuse survivor because someone
grabbed his junk at a party in a drunken
horseplay that's the same as Harvey
Weinstein raping an actress and I don't
think so
and of course you get you get attacked
for logically separating the idea of an
unwanted hand on an ass and then getting
gang-raped in a parking lot and the [ __ ]
beat out of you Matt Damon gone to a lot
of trouble trying to explain the
differences between what really is a
problem and then what is just you know
life when the story about Aziz Ansari
going out on a date with someone was
written up in babe the response to that
was kind of like you know that was an
unfortunate evening but it's clearly it
has nothing to do with what we're
talking about when it's Harvey Weinstein
well it's the beginning of that was the
beginning of the end that was the
beginning of the moment when me too
seriously had to step back and say okay
well she had a bad day or okay Terry
Crews didn't want to drunk an agent from
way more
that touches dick okay but to equate it
with that is it means then everything
everything is sexual assault and then
that means nothing is do you think that
Hollywood oddly because it likes to
always put itself as you know it's at
the forefront it's the avant-garde we
are the most beautiful people there are
the richest people the most creative
worries at the front of things in fact
when it comes to questions about
equality in the workplace that actually
the entertainment industry is way way
way at the back of it oh the bottom of
the butt the bottom your very bottom I
mean other industries have kind of dealt
with it you ever been dealing with this
because among other reasons there's
economic pressures to do that yeah
completely should go back a little bit
to different kind of genre or media what
is the role for you of television a lot
of people talk about this as a golden
age of television both at you know in in
traditional places like ABC NBC you know
broadcast networks but also because of
Amazon Netflix and other services you
know we I was thinking when you were
talking about you know the novel the the
social function of the novel in the 19th
century in one way was to take a thick
slice of society across the society and
show how all these different parts
worked you have shows like could be The
Sopranos it could be the Americans and
guess the Breaking Bad I mean these
across very different platforms
performing that function is that were
the energy oh yeah that is definitely
where the energy is I'm not sure the art
is there yet but the energy is there and
certainly the way the audience reacts to
these series really outdoes any kind of
reaction a movie can get certainly like
I get out can turn into this like you
know media made thing but in terms of an
audience reacting on in a in a large a
large audience reacting to these shows
that is what those shows do and I know a
lot of people who used to be somewhat
voracious readers I was just talking to
my 80 year old aunt the other day who
really when I was growing up with read
every book every new novel she just
doesn't do it anymore and for her TV
series or the new novel I can lose
myself in a TV series for 13
14 hours in a way that I used to lose
myself in a book and I think you know
whenever I say that the novel is dead or
is dying I'm not saying that I don't
like the novel I have 20 stacked up but
my nights and I'm constantly reading
novels I've got to going right now but I
am saying that their function in society
is completely different I'm reading the
Richard Burton Diaries the actor a
wonderful writer an absolutely wonderful
writer and I'm now about 1969 1970 and
in every entry entry he's talking about
what book he or Elisabeth is reading and
they're reading everything and they're
carrying paperbacks with them on planes
they were kind of like our phones in a
weird way I'm realizing while reading
this that everyone had a novel everyone
was talking about a novel novels have
this kind of cultural weight that they
simply do not at all now have now you
can still enjoy them but there is you
know that's a that's just that's just
something that you have to live through
I guess in terms the same way you have
to live for the fact that movies don't
matter as much in that same way or in a
strange way well it goes back and forth
we could depending on the community
you're part of for me as somebody who
grew up listening to punk and rock music
it's clear like that is no longer an
idiom of the masses in the way that
hip-hop and then certain subsets because
that's become so diversified now there's
a little difference well let me just ask
you as an as somebody whose fame was
first as a novelist and you say you're
not saying that you hate novels or
anything like that love no is it is it
difficult to realize that that chosen
you know media medium that genre doesn't
doesn't matter the way that it did for
you or for the world 40 years ago its
life it's just life I wanted to be a
filmmaker and I wanted to be a musician
I mean I was in bands in high school I
thought I was gonna be a musician I was
a songwriter I wrote hundreds of songs I
thought that was where I was gonna
that's where I was gonna make my mark
but I was also always writing and I
always thought well the writing is going
to lead to filmmaking and yet the novel
kind of happened and I realized I had
four or five more novels I wanted to
write and then I'll get those out of the
way and then I'll get to filmmaking
music by there that's what you do
it is pretty much what I did but the
problem is that movies changed and the
way of making movies changed and it's
much harder to make a movie well to make
a certain kind of movie look I could go
out tomorrow one of my scripts and try
to shoot it on my iPhone I suppose with
some kids in the neighborhood I don't
want to do that I don't want to see that
kind of movie and the kind of movie I
want to make they're just not making
anymore so that's kind of where you know
what I'm trying to figure out and also
you know in the and also I do believe in
the TV series is an incredibly valid way
to tell stories tell stories long-form
and to explore themes explore character
I'm often like kind of getting a little
impatient with movies now that are 100
minutes long 110 minutes long and I
think God this would be so much better
as a series now I whereas any people are
like a two-hour movie I'm not sitting
through that well you know a 2-out a
two-and-a-half-hour movie made two
billion dollars this year and that's all
the Marvel movies about you know 150
minutes and I'm not so sure about that I
remember going to see don't ask me why
one of the Harry Potter movies add a
matinee and I realize oh god I went to
this on a Saturday and it was sold out
with kids I was with a friend of mine oh
god only knows what we look like in the
middle of this thing this theater in
Westwood
and I thought this is gonna be a nice is
that where you met your millennial
boyfriend no that's funny no I just I
just know yeah I know what you mean know
it but it must have been a fantastic
experience to be in a theater filled
with kids watching a Harry Potter movie
pinata dies if you hear a pin drop
you could hear a pin drop and I was I
looked around and I said my god there's
not a peep this is a two hour and 20
minute movie and it just really depends
on the content and so there's certainly
there but look I gotta say I watch
pilots all the time that are recommended
on social media or a friend I've never
heard of most of them because we're 800
shows on and so you know you kinda have
to weed it out and I turn off most of
them like 10 to 15 minutes in going this
there is no way this needs to be 20
hours
and so I mean it just depends on the
talent the one beef I have with TV
content is that it still is driven by
the writer it's still driven by the
showrunner and yet it is a visual piece
of work
it is filmed it has a camera it has
actors
it has scenes in it that you have to
like you know edit and shoot and the
money sometimes is there but mostly TV
still is kind of locked in the writer is
the star and I think we've got to get to
a point where the director becomes as
much of the star and you can start using
the camera as a character as you do in
most films most films movies use the
camera as a character and they also the
money to do that TV economics are a
little different though you know
bloodline I think cost Netflix or
whatever produce that like you know 350
million dollars to make those you know I
think those three seasons so money is
being spent
I just don't think there's this moment
where the visual is coming together with
the writing to produce something
cinematic but you've been on the
forefront at least in terms of when you
the way that you finance and kind of
shot the the canyons yeah as well as you
know moving onto patreon and things like
that on the forefront of new kind of
models what is the appeal of that and do
you think well these will these models
replace the old model or will they
constantly be supplements to a kind of
larger broad-based studio like system
where most of the money and most of the
talent is going now they're all gone
everything that they're mostly gone and
also the the appeal was that it's the
only way I could do it I mean to the
appeal I mean how I have a you know I
was asked to write and write a web
series and it was kind of like really a
web series well it's basically an hour
40 minute movie that's what the season
is and it's just cut into 10 minutes 10
episodes and given a million dollars to
do this and 14 days or whatever the
shooting schedule was and I thought
great that this is gonna be a movie in a
way and so I took that but you know the
years and years and years of trying to
get movies made is
really grim and you either get into a
kind of absurdist kind of frame of mind
like thinking this is all it's such a
joke what's gonna land what Luke I mean
I have scripts that I've written that I
cannot believe they got made whether
it's these low-budget horror films or
compared to passion projects of mine
that you know seem to be getting made
are 10 years in development of some kind
so the movie business is just fraught
with a kind of creative peril that you
have to either just like deal with what
is your favorite text or movie I don't
know if there's a song about it about
the Hollywood process and how
soul-killing it is or how great it is I
don't know the song about well I doubt
there's a song about it but I mean you
know dude well the kid stays in the
picture or the player or oh you know
well you know look getting back to the
seventies thing I think Easyriders
raging bulls by Peter biscuit is kind of
a great but that's about a very specific
era it's not really about you know the
and and the air has changed so much if
you told anybody in 1977 that this is
what the business was going to be they
go you're crazy and I remember being one
of those naive people who was having
conversations with two of my friends
were screenwriters in the late 90s when
some movie opened that grossed like a
huge amount over the weekend and we were
all kind of laughing about it and my
friend said you know there's going to be
a time in about 20 years where movies
are gonna studio movies are gonna cost
20 250 million dollars they're gonna
open in 40,000 theaters across the globe
they're gonna make about a billion
dollars in three weeks and I'm gonna
replace by a new one and we were all
kind of thinking that's so alarmist it's
not gonna happen how can that happen
well that is what has happened that
friend was extremely impressed unit but
the but uh it's it's constantly changing
and they're kind of constantly running
after it was changing even from the 70s
into the 80s where you know agencies
took over because the new Hollywood
failed it ultimately failed and by the
way did the new Hollywood fail because
of the excesses of the directors or of
the people who could really make demands
or was it something else I mean is it
you know one too many sorcerers by
William Friedkin
or Heaven's Gate right you know flop and
then suddenly it's like okay you're done
and we're making Top Gun yeah that's
exactly what happened and why shouldn't
it I mean if I was running a studio I
mean I would also like and I was gonna
lose my job because I'm letting Michael
trim you know make a four-hour western
that I you know full of smoke and you
can't even tell what's going on but you
know that is this the natural order of
things the the idea that filmmakers were
felt that that there was so much
possibility in the medium that it made
them so grandly ambitious is ultimately
their downfall I mean that's kind of the
the tragedy of the tragedy of that of
that era would do video games loom in
your cultural landscape because when you
talk about a billion dollar weekend
the you know the ones honor the one
medium that can routinely do that or
videos and do they factor in yet and do
you think that they either have or can
achieve a kind of artistic sensibility
where they replace perhaps you know
movies or TV shows or a function has
knob there it is it they already have my
boyfriend plays them all the time and
their grand narratives they're
beautifully produced the imagery is
often stunning characters that talk to
each other storylines that you can
choose because they're interactive you
can play with other people I I'm too old
for it I missed the boat on that I was
what my video games were space invaders
and like Galaga or whatever but it's not
not I'm not as an as adept as he is now
and I'm still older and so I appreciate
these older forms more than he does but
I can I get it I can tell why my
boyfriend would spend ten hours on the
weekend playing a video game that he was
completely immersed in co-creating it
decided to go that way rather than this
way on on this on this play and of
course I mean of course
Dunkirk seems boring to them you know
well how could he sit through you know
well to go back to you know I think
Christopher Nolan is one of these these
actors who is
dunkirk was stunning - yeah and III
don't mean to you know just generate
generationally beat up on Millennials i
my my least funds who are no they were
also like wow that was like a totally
[ __ ] different kind of war movie and
you know much more profound all all the
reason for it well to talk about what
what is the social function that you
think video games play then for
Millennials if a novel was a way of
getting news you know of telling like
what you know what's new in the world or
to experience a different time and place
what what do video games particularly
when they're being played online you
know in mass participation what what are
they doing but don't they do the same
thing more or less I mean I I think they
do the same thing as the movie or the
novel does just in different ways I mean
when I see my boyfriend and his friends
talking about a new video game and
talking about it with the kind of fervor
that my friends and I used to talk about
a short story collection that was
published in 1983 whether it was Raymond
Carver or whoever right you know times
have changed I mean the sensibility has
changed and it's just the same way that
my boyfriend consumes news I mean he
doesn't trust the energy the the legacy
media so he only watches news on on you
know a lot of them from all ages a lot
of improv or does not watch Infowars
he's more the Young Turks and he's into
that side of the aisle so how does that
sit with you how did you define yourself
politically I never defined myself
politically until about two or three
years ago when I started following this
election I never really followed
elections before I was never interested
in politics I had friends who worked in
politics in fact I was living with a
friend who ran a gubernatorial campaign
I mean I was involved in a relationship
with one in the early 90s in Virginia
and it was such a turn-off it was so not
my scene I was just so not interested
that I always checked out and I never
saw that my books were particularly
political I've never took a political
stance but something about the way this
election was being covered began to
become interesting to me and I noticed
that you know it was partisan and I
noticed that the media had a narrative
that they were building
and I thought well that media that the
media narrative is kind of interesting
but I don't really think it's true and
so that kind of was an awakening
watching how the media covered the
election of 26 was the narrative they
you say the media was building the
narrative was clicking open to the New
York Times in the summer of I believe
2015 and the headline on the front page
was about Donald Trump saying megyn
kelly bled from whatever and I stared at
it for a very long time and I thought
that's the top headline in the New York
Times and it was kind of a moment that I
still remember when why is this a top
headline and then I began to I mean I
already was sensing that there was a
resistance a big resistance to trauma
and I thought that's really interesting
are they going to get away with it is
this going to work how was the Clinton
narrative going to play itself out
because certainly the press isn't that
in love with her and so it became this
kind of fascinating story for me that
really wasn't even about policy or
really wasn't even about you know
Democrat Republican conservative liberal
I'd never considered myself any of them
I'm you know I when I say independent my
boyfriend says it's a cop-out you know
you can't be independent what about
you've got to be on some side but I
genuinely am and if you check my social
media have nothing about politics on it
I did start having an annoyance with the
narratives of each of the campaigns and
I began to see that there that neither
one was really quite honest but the
Trump resistance in the narrative in
this media narrative was almost shocking
to me and that's kind of when I became
not I wouldn't say I was involved in the
election I wouldn't say that I had any
and I'd vote for I did not vote no you
didn't vote at all I did not vote it on
now in the California I mean what am I
gonna do I mean this whole idea well
you've got a vote you've got it it's a
it's a symbol of something whatever it's
very hard to make that symbol mean
anything when you're living in Beverly
Hills or when you're living in West
Hollywood when you're living in
California it's just like whatever this
is like an overwhelmingly lunatic
do you worry and if somebody who you
know if you the one thing that was great
about 70 cinema is also the one of the
great things about the 70s America is
everything was apocalyptic the world yes
you know either the second coming of
Jesus literally was about to happen or
the Cold War was about to become a
thermonuclear disaster overpopulation
despoil ation of the environment you
name it the world was about to address
do you worry that we are entering a new
era of apocalyptic ellipta sysm my
mother finds all of this alarmist
rhetoric ridiculous she's 75 and she
talks do you really want to know about a
worse in time go back to 1968 I will
tell you then that was a scary moment
compared to where we are now in 2016
2017
that was really paranoia
a real edge was in the air and you had
people being assassinated and you had
riots and it was that she says was I
mean I was four but she says that was
scary this is just a lot of people
screaming at each other and this notion
of creating narratives is something that
is I don't know keeps me invested in the
media and watching how this whole thing
is going to turn out
it really has in the last couple of
months gotten reached a fever pitch of
hysteria that I don't see how anybody
can defend right but but can they
sustain it or and if not it this what is
sustained what's the button like where's
the reset button - well I thought the
reset button was gonna be a year after
the election
I thought the reset button was gonna
happen and it just got worse and I see
it because I live with it I live with
someone who has I believe Trump
derangement syndrome and I told him this
many times we get into it back and forth
I really do I I swear it's okay we're
gonna have him on next so you know equal
time it's the one thing that is
I am but I do but I do see it and I do
see it in a knee-jerk reaction to a lot
of my liberal friends when I'll say
something that I think is semi logical
and or all say some well no it's not
even though I'm defending Trump I'm just
not agreeing with them and clawing my
face off in anguish along with them
and when I don't do that so you don't
believe he's a Russian that he's the
Laurence Harvey character from The
Manchurian Candidate well we're one
phone call away from you know Moscow
taking over the one work of yours and
actually of that broader period that
seems to really speak to Millennials for
reasons that escaped me yeah is American
psyche probably more the movie than the
the novel because I suspect not as many
of read the novel that had such a
scandalous opening I rather a scandalous
publication history it was such a
flashpoint the movie came out it was
seen as you know problematic it was a
social problem it was something we need
to do something about this now it is on
it seems if you put if you have even a
basic cable package that is playing
somewhere somehow some time for the you
know 24 hours a day
what does your millennial friend think
about that do they like that - and what
if so what are what are they seeing in
that and what do you think the
longer-term message of that is well I
don't know I think as the as the writer
which was written all this books and I
pay attention to what's going on with
them I actually was I actually think
less than zero to a strange degree and
it's also been remade as a hulu series
right now and with people were actually
21 and 18 and 19 and staying very far
away it's a sidelight of what's great
about older movies about kids is that
they were always like you know cat you
mentioned Carrie
yeah John Travolta was like 45 and it
was grease took place on a planet where
you start high school when you turn
third
no but but but of course American cycle
is the most famous book and it's like
the most copy so I'm not ok but um you
know I don't know I don't know I think
they I know there was a lot of
referencing of American Psycho in after
the election there was a lot of Donald
Trump American Psycho stops going it is
Patrick Bateman will become president
right and he is mentioned a lot in the
book which was written in the late 80s
because so many people I knew when I was
doing my initial research with The Wall
Street guys loved him they loved the art
of the deal they loved Trump he was an
aspirational figure you know I guess you
know I don't care first of all what they
feel about it in terms of um and I you
know I don't know I mean I think that um
well obviously there's something about
this book and this character that kept
has kept resonating and I thought it was
such a strange personal experimental
novel that I thought okay fifteen
thousand comedies I think that hasn't
come and I'll write something more
commercial from publisher because
they'll be so grateful and I'll publish
this novel and for some bizarre reason
that the writer cannot control it has
just kept resonating throughout the
decades and I guess it must be because
it is in many ways can be seen as an
anti rich anti one-percent narrative
certainly it can be read that way even
though I saw it as a personal novel
about my own demons having to as a boy
having to become an adult and my
fighting against that did not want to
become a man and certainly did not want
to become a man with the within a
society that values this this is this
which is money money money and you know
status is a heterosexuality in a
particular way I mean how much does your
changing or your evolving statements I
mean this is the first time we've met I
don't know you at all except through
your work and through reading interviews
but it also seems Patrick Bateman had I
mean part of if you're going to be a
master of the universe part of that is
being heterosexual and he that seems to
be part of the issue there but American
Psycho is about that moment when the Dan
defecation of the American male was
happening and it was happening with
what I saw happening during that decade
was straight young male society was
aping the attitudes of gay society they
were getting really into shape they were
getting tan they were getting their hair
cut a certain way they were inordinately
into their background tweeze all Erebus
hair care product right and that was
kind of a spark for American Psycho and
for detailing Patrick Bateman's
ridiculous routines and his obsession
with himself because I saw that
happening and that became part of the
fabric of that novel not necessarily
because I was gay I never really was
interested in writing about whether I
was gay or not always seemed like a very
boring part of my life to some degree or
another and I always felt that I was in
the glass closet I never was someone who
said I was straight I never said I had
girlfriends I just avoided the question
more or less or played with it were
evading it up until about the late 90s
early 2000s when I just said I'm just
tired I don't care anymore
and I also felt that the reputation that
I had was kind of in a weird way
solidified it wasn't gonna be you know
it was this wasn't going to change it in
a way that I genuinely felt it would
have changed it in 1985 I definitely
think there were gay fiction sections
and bookstores and writers were
definitely relegated to a vague a bin
rather than just the total banana and
usually we want to be next to Ruby fruit
jungle that's what I'm here where David
Levitt yeah or whoever the big gay
writers were of that moment and so I
even though you know I someone once told
me I mean the American Psycho is like
the gayest book ever written and I said
yeah pretty gay because of Patrick
Bateman so [ __ ] gay but it was but
now oddly enough it's not looked at that
way it's looked at as oh this is what
you do and I've gone I cannot tell you
how many you know email or fan stuff
about how I taught young men to shave
because Patrick Bateman has a very you
know wash the face keep it wet put a
moisturizer on and then put it put a
cream never a foam I never a foam always
a cream over the moisturizer use strokes
that go down and then do up in here and
it was like I was
heritage [ __ ] I was reading Esquire I'm
GQ thought this would be hilarious in a
novel let's put this in a novel and to
me and then you know that it takes on a
life of its own
you mentioned less than zero and in a
lot of ways that is yeah I mean this is
true both a lot of writers or creators
that their first big work you know the
DNA is there and you everything that
you're going to do is in there want that
to a certain degree
what is it about that book that you
think person is or is it partly that we
at the time that came out okay that's
something that if you go to an elite
private school you you are beyond
scarcity like you don't you just don't
have to think about money you get a
Bennington you don't even have you're
not even pressured enough where you've
got to go to a real Ivy League school
you you know you're okay you're
post-scarcity everything's gonna be okay
and that produces in the characters
aimlessness and a lack of meaning and
even the will it seems to kind of create
existentially meaning from day to day is
part of the enduring appeal of that is
that the rest of society has kind of
caught up to that there's obviously a
lot of bad [ __ ] in America but by and
large people you know we're free to do
whatever we want which is kind of
oftentimes a terrifying apparition
it's short it's short and it's very easy
to read I don't think a chapter is more
than two or three paragraphs and it goes
down super super easy
that is what my guess is after all and I
think the other thing about it is that
it is kind of the first book I realize
now that the kids were as bad as the
parents in most adolescent fiction the
adolescents are victims they're victims
of older people and their corruption and
lesson zero says no no these kids are
kind of as bad as their parents are and
there was something about reading a book
where young people were openly aping the
attitudes and the lifestyles of these
parents that I think was kind of a
kind of a kick to people kind of fantasy
that people that young people really
thought was cool
whereas I wasn't thinking about that at
all all right in the book but really the
takeaway the first five or six years and
still is that people young people read
that book as I don't [ __ ] how cool
Beverly Hills how cool it would be to
move to LA and to be in that crowd and
being in Mercedes at night snorting
align the while going having a drink at
Spago and all of this stuff even you
know and that's true I get it there was
debt and I when I got fan letters actual
letters if people can remember exactly I
got fan letters from like everywhere
from Indiana to the UK to New Delhi New
Delhi kids in New Delhi who had read it
who said this is the coolest book I want
to go to you know I it seems like such
an amazing lifestyle to live now of
course half the people did get it that
it was you know kind of my my own we
might add a lesson on we in many ways I
look at as a work of juvenilia I it's
very hard for me to open that book now
without seeing the 18 19 year old kind
of putting this book together and I'm
very earnest fashioned la is very bad
and there are very bad people here but I
think what saves the book is that I
implicate the narrator the narrator is
just as bad at everyone else he's not
really that judgmental he kind of like
it's squirmy when he wants to how old
the girl they're gonna gang rape is and
she's not quite 13 but she's 11 and
that's like a moment for him in a way
that's like the only kind of moral and
so I think there's an honesty to that
there wasn't some sort of like
moralizing judgement going on explicitly
in that book though of course it's
probably there everywhere if you want to
if you want to see it and so I think
that is part of the appeal of why the
book has still has readers what 30 years
later 30 25 years later whatever
kardashian-west lobbied the President on
his Johnson's behalf and yesterday he
commuted her sentence citing her good
behavior and rehabilitation I have to
say I never get starstruck I was
starstruck over the Oval Office one of
the things in preparing for this
interview and listening to some of your
recent podcasts and other things I was
thinking about less than zero and you
know in a way the Kardashians or kim
kardashian is kind of a character out of
that book you know two or three
generations removed and you have talked
in a recent podcast she talked about how
she is actually also you know and she's
famous for being famous she is an
incredibly effective communicator of
things like criminal justice reform what
does that Trump she has gone well he
actually got people sprung from jail I
mean this is something that you know
Angela Merkel should have talked with
Kim Kardashian before she came to talk
with Donald Trump if she wanted to get
some money for Germany or something talk
a little bit about the ways in which
somebody like a Kim Kardashian is kind
of the you know you know less than zero
three or four point oh but it's a
different story now because she's not
she's coming out of that Mel you but
seems to be pretty earnest and also
seems to be making a positive difference
in the world
well you know when you based your career
on a sex tape that was probably you know
many lawyers are probably involved with
in terms of getting that lead address
probably right it did not appear by
right you have someone who gets it and I
wrote about the Kardashians and about I
think it was 2010 for Playboy I wrote a
piece about how there is a kind of post
Empire celebrity a celebrity that says
[ __ ] you to the propriety that celebrity
is supposed to have the behaved
celebrity who is aw shucks I'm just a
humble actor and I'm just the and it
taught us a certain celebrity who
understands how media works and uses it
to their advantage
I bet Kim Kardashian a couple of times
she is not what she appears to be
there's a lot of calculation and there
is it's a performative life in a way
that is live in for us in terms of what
it's lived out in calabasas it's much
more naturalistic and it's much more
like oh let's see if we can do this to
make this happen so you know I as being
extremely smart in terms of being a
businesswoman in terms of building this
Empire of course along with Chris
Kardashian or mother
and also just being able to read the
mood of the public for her benefit and
that is something for example a lot of
people who are for example complaining
about Trump that he's orange Hitler that
is evil just don't get and I don't
particularly think Kim Kardashian or
Kanye I mean I know they they say they
like Trump and all that um I don't know
how much about policy they really care
about I think there's something about
Trump's dragon energy that appeals to
Kanye and I think there's something that
Kim located that she could use from
Trump and so she just went and made it
happen like she's made everything else
happened if celebrities would just calm
the [ __ ] down
believe me Trump will take your call you
want something done you want to fix
something there's something going on you
know I really do believe that if you
called him because he still enthrall
it's a celebrity that a lot of these
celebrities who are screaming about him
and screaming about Paul's everything
you never sit down with the men we talk
it out and who knows he might be swayed
by celebrity and I think that that is
there was an unfortunate moment where
the hysteria about him is that such a
fever pitch that people don't realize
that there might be a pathway of
communication at the end of the day he
heard me out we got the job done
you mentioned post Empire what was the
Empire the Empire was roughly from post
end of end of World War two when we were
at the height of our prosperous nests
and education and the boomer generation
became the best educated financially you
know well-off generation and that was
the Empire and Empire art was a
reflection of that it was kind of a
reflection of propriety how great we are
how cool we are even when we're talking
about our own faults and our own flaws
there still was a kind of Empire
glamorous glamorous Ness
to it and then in post Empire that
seemed to be falling away what what
ended the Empire what ended the Empire I
thought 9/11 and the empire that limped
along for a few more years I think Obama
helped end the Empire how did he well
the shock of Obama just being a black
man entering into the White House was a
big turning point in terms of how people
saw the world and how they saw how the
American Empire which they thought was
working in a certain way could actually
allow this amp and a big shock to the
system much as I suppose Trump in a
different way at post post an empire
president did and I do think that there
was a desire among people who couldn't
deal with the propriety of a kind of
behavior you saw it in the arts first
and I saw it all over the place
beginning after the Obama election in
2009 2010 reality TV certainly really
the Kardashians helped bring this into
play and you saw with artists as as
disparate as Eminem with the way he
would record an autobiographical album
about his divorce and ending with him
murdering his wife and you compared it
to like Bob Dylan's blood on the tracks
whereas a very elegant very mournful
very stylish piece of music or Bruce
Springsteen with Tunnel of Love and he
just started to notice that the albums
that were being made and the expression
was much more I do not give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] this is me I think the
Charlize
meltdown was one of those pivotal
moments where we saw celebrity in full
meltdown
I do not care guys follow me I ran a
night and you saw him like that's not in
a lot of disparate places during 2010
2011 2012 and then there was a push back
on it and corporate culture began
putting this back into the bottle it
didn't want to allow for it anymore and
corporate culture one the post Empire
attitude that you saw in a lot of a lot
of artists just was considered I don't
know too much it was a disruptor Rosanna
is an example of this then of you know
she gets the reboot but she's not
domestic domesticated again so she gets
bounced right well I mean Rosanna is a
victim of corporate culture just the way
that James Gunn is just the way that a
lot of people are right now to some
degree or another many men who got
sucked up into the tidal wave of me -
were just bores they were just dicks you
know they didn't do anything illegal
necessarily they were just [ __ ] so I
don't know I think that corporate
culture in a way is definitely it is a
form of censorship and it's a form of
shutting down the artists and shutting
down free speech and that's that's just
where we that's where we already know
and but you're also I mean when you say
corporate culture you're not again this
isn't from The Young Turks perspective
that you know corporations are evil
because they're capitalistic etc you're
no I'm talking about free expression
that's what I'm talking about it from an
artist standpoint I don't think it
really bothers people who aren't who do
who don't depend on expressing
themselves as a living that 20:18 has
been really horrible in that way in
terms of seeing people punished for a
tweet or for something they said eight
years ago that was a joke and then being
punished and banished for it is is not a
particularly teachable moment right now
it's just like you know do you do you
see
a need for a different type of discourse
or a resetting of okay so then what what
goes into this well look i think that
what should have happened with Roseanne
Barr is that ABC should have mmediately
said we're running a live program on ABC
Friday night at 8 o'clock where we
having Roseanne Barr we're having
Valerie Jarrett we're having the cast of
Roseanne we're having some black
activists I was going to say throw in
are some of the chorus from Hamilton oh
yeah sure you do that and let's have a
talk about what happened on Monday when
this week came out let's have a moment
where we're all going to have a
conversation first of all the ratings
for that would have been astronomical
they would have been huge and whatever
ad time you could have sold would have
been just you know and that would have
you could have even been selling ads
during that and you could have had a
real moment of let's talk about this
instead of just firing some why wouldn't
something like that happen is it a
failure of vision or is it a failure of
nerve or it doesn't serve corporate
because it gets too complicated and
people don't like that because it
touches on very complicated realities
about humor about race about priviledged
about free expression and it's just too
much to take that thing I think people
just can't deal it it's turned into a
very black-and-white world right now or
red and orange or Laurel and yannis
whatever you wanna call it I didn't mean
to make a race thing out of the black
and white but it really has become this
this thing whether the dialogue isn't
happening in the way that it should and
I think it was perfectly expressed in
that what happened with Mark Duplass
where he said it's time for us to reach
across the aisle and listen to the other
side and you know he used ben shapiro as
an example of the person we should
listen to and of course he got
excoriated for it marthy play i think
the mark Duplass apology is one of those
depressing things that happened this
year and him deleting that tweet is one
of the most important how can someone
who you really like and he had a good
time with and he's one of the good ones
over there whatever mark Duplass said 48
hours later be a racist homophobic
[ __ ] jerk a disaster it's like I mean
that was and I know Marvin I had marked
on my podcast and I thought really this
is where the left is this is where the
resistance is this is where the
Hollywood Silver Lake hipster attitude
is that you're really this much but
that's the right you know and these are
bad terms because they really don't know
why but but then the right is the reason
why James Gunn got fired because a bunch
of people there were like hey look at
this
no no corporate culture is the reason
why James gladden got fire not Mike's
renovage and not like no it is corporate
culture got it just like corporate
culture got ABC got Roseanne Barr fired
no it wasn't you know it wasn't the left
it wasn't the right it was corporate
culture all arrows go back to corporate
culture in terms of this kind of firing
and that's true with all of the men who
were you know fired from the meeting
movement it's just that we're not taking
a case by case by case and looking at
and I do think now with Chris Hardwick
giving his show back
I think there's is a blow a push back on
this kind of and I think the whatever
half a million names for the petition to
rehire James Gunn I think there is a
real pushback on this that we cannot
just be judge and jury in an hour after
if something happens and people are just
banished I think there was kind of a
shock at first but I think there's a
natural inclination a human inclination
now to say maybe this isn't really the
way to do it this isn't the way to have
the conversation and we got to have it
in a different way all right well we're
gonna leave it there and we're going to
point people to Bret Easton Ellis's
podcast on patreon you should look it up
because that's a place where you'll be
having conversations right not you know
hour-long or two hour long show trials
correct okay so that's one place and you
also have a book coming out next year
yeah it's being edited right now it'll
be published by Knopf and we don't even
really know what the title is do you
know what it's about it's about
corporate culture it is a nonfiction
book about corporate culture and freedom
of speech and about
how the the silencing of artists okay
that sounds like a theme that will will
stay fresh at least for another six
months yeah if not another six centuries
thank you so much for talking thank you
for a reason I'm Nicholas Peck
you